Well,
I think fashion has gotten to a point
where it's sort of like mini Hollywood,
you know,
it's,
it's actress light.
Uh,
it's,
it's mellow drama,
small.
It's a,
you know,
it's a sitcom.
It's not the full length feature movie.
It's fashioned,
provides a certain drama.
It's got the ego,
it's got the beauty,
it's got the glamor that Hollywood has.
Um,
and because it's not,
know we can't get in behind Meryl
Streep's dressing room.
We can't get backstage at the filming of
that.
We can't see when camera,
um,
uh,
who was just on,
um,
Charlie just did a nude scene and they
did it at night and 4:00 in the morning
because they didn't want anyone to know
and only the director and Charlene's new
and Duh,
Dah,
Dah.
Um,
uh,
we can't get behind the scenes on that.
You can't do that.
The celebs won't let you do that.
Hollywood won't allow us.
So,
you know,
fashion sort of Hollywood light on some
level and you can get into a bit of the
drama and the Glamor and the beauty that
Hollywood provides.
Um,
and there's also,
you know,
a lot of Ecos,
so you get it,
you get a little bit of the,
uh,
you a little bit of the storyline as
well.
They've got to look great and that's
their image.
And similarly,
you know,
John Galleano made it out of the,
the slight obscurity when,
you know,
his dresses were worn by,
actresses on the catwalk,
uh,
on the red carpet.
I mean,
um,
so,
you know,
it's a great symbiotic relationship.
Actresses need to look glamorous,
they need to be photographed and
similarly,
designers want to keep their street cred
with the general public who's watching
the Oscars,
who's watching all these celebs,
reading all the weeklies,
looking at all of the online sites to
see what they're wearing when they go
out,
when they go to award ceremonies.
So,
you know,
the Hollywood end fashion has gotten
into bed together.
Um,
and it's working nicely actually for
both of them.
I'm always riveted by Madonna,
you know,
she continues to more,
even at age 50,
51.
Uh,
she was backstage at Marc Jacobs.
He had address,
you know,
slightly speechless because I think
she's got great style.
Um,
and if not,
she's got unbelievable balls to have the
style that she wants to have when she
wants to have it.
So I think she's someone that I've
always found to be interesting.
Um,
I think occasionally Katie Holmes has
had great personal style,
is kind of gracious in the way she gets
dressed.
Uma Thurman was a model.
I love her style all the time.
She looks just great in clothes.
Um,
you know,
beyonce is sexy and beautiful and route
and I love the way she looks too.
I'm very,
very different.
Yeah,
well,
I think of a generation.
The blogs are,
um,
I'd like to consider ours the cut,
which is,
you know,
going through the roof and it's record
breaking numbers,
um,
during New York fashion week last week
that people are coming more to the blogs
and good smart ones that have a point of
view that tell them the news that
synthesize it also a bit of a,
you know,
cutting edge,
shall we say,
not to,
to,
to use the part of cut.
Uh,
uh,
I think that's a generational change
that,
that really is happening.
I don't think the celebrities are in
general,
um,
you know,
I think the Olson's have great style and
that's an exception to the rule.
Um,
and they're also doing a great line of
clothing,
kind of cool classics called the row.
Um,
but in general,
no,
I think it comes from the designers.
They're the ones that set the trends.
They're the ones that create the desire,
create the passion,
create the whole aura around what you
want to get or where or see in any given
season.
Um,
and fashioned traditionally goes from,
you know,
you're too young,
last fall,
this fall it was about eighties and
leather and tight and sequence and
shoulders on belts or forties and more
conservative version of that same
silhouette.
And for spring so far it's very
romantic.
It's quite loose normous amount of
texture to fabrics and ruffles or pearls
or rushing or bright strong color things
that are very eye-popping.
So again,
you're seeing the antithesis of what
came before.
Um,
fashion designers tend to be tired of
what they've just seen for six months
and they want something completely
different and fresh.
So if you,
if you,
if you see a season of black,
you can bet that the next season's going
to be white.
If you see a season where it's short and
tight,
you can sort of put your money on,
it might be long and lives um,
or looser and slightly more poetic and
it's point of view.
I,
I think the designer today that really
designs for women,
um,
that's leading the pack on that.
With that in mind,
um,
is Alvera Barabbas for law va.
I think his ability to design his
technique,
his technique,
his,
his literal ability to design a dress
and know how to technically do that is
um,
got many peers.
I think Alabama really understands a
woman.
I think he understands not only her
body,
but her psyche,
how she wants to be alluring,
how she wants to feel.
Um,
I think he's really entered into that
space and I therefore,
I think he designs with that in mind
along with an unbelievable technical
ability to make perfectly beautiful
clothing,
um,
seem effortless and have a great ease
and sensuality that's very,
very,
very accomplished and very difficult to
come by.
So I would have to give my stars to the
man with the most style or ability to
create that style.
Ultimately,
a woman's got to have that style because
she's putting on something that somebody
made.
And I think,
I think alvero elbaz would be my vote
for today.